what's going on with you and your
boyfriend Kevin Kevin we're gonna be
together 19 years that's in like three
weeks and what do you say what's going
on let me ask you something you're an
extraordinary looking woman you're
telling me
Hollywood celebrities aren't hitting on
you left and right no men have hit on
you
in the 19 years you've been we're sure
absolutely I just imagine a slew of
[ __ ] famous guys hitting on you a lot
is it true or false I people have
inquired whether I am in a relationship
and then when they find out find out I'm
in a relationship they move on no they
don't normal your parents hated Kevin it
was like a moment no they they fat cut
off your tuition right when you were
going to college cause of Kevin dad was
a little upset dad was a little upset
because he wasn't greed where is Kevin
there is easy here yeah let me bring him
in let me bring in Kevin let me talk
time for me to suffer look at you oh by
the way you guys have been together 19
[ __ ] years like you supported her
financially for all the years you paid
back all her loans did all that when we
got when we got started she's with you
yeah guilt I sometimes feel badly
because if she did go with an a-lister
over me her life would be so easy and I
feel because I feel bad because I can't
always be always the a-lister that you
felt she should have gone off with any
of them any not Hall Pass no go go like
the way you really love her that much
[ __ ] crazy I feel bad
I always felt guilty because I he's like
she could be happy to get anybody and
have the easiest [ __ ] life because
you have been terrorized in the business
and by the way she's not the only one
and the women especially Howard Maria
why do you not respect Kevin enough to
marry him wait no no Howard I mean what
is telling him now like we have to do
this like people are getting older and
our family's like we have to do this we
just have to do it now it's over we got
and he's like no I want a big affair
Kris Jenner says she's gonna be the
godmother and throw the party I want the
big party in a mic can we just go like I
think
should Miriam just to keep you in line
but I'm gonna give the microphone to
Maria's a long time boy say something
you know I do and because it's been so
you all about to propose to me I'm gonna
die
oh my god it felt like I was about to
propose right now no it was just it was
so emotional to hear you say everything
your boyfriend of 19 years wants to talk
to you Maria yeah go ahead
listening everything you said guy well
with tears too because I think about
what we both have been through as a
couple and when we wanted to to be
together
you know we couldn't write because
people didn't want us together and then
you being her parents yeah and family it
was literally like the last 17 or 18
years of us you know fighting together
and me defending her as best I could
you know it reminds me just how much I
do love you and and although I said that
this isn't a proposal I want to ask you
something real you make me the happiest
man on earth and would you marry me I
have to go down a knee and get off the
bike I'm sorry get down on your knee
get the mic near you put on some
headphones headphones what did you say
it's not a joke this I wouldn't joke
about I love you so much
and this shows meant so much to both of
us this is the first thing we listen to
together 19 years in that basement on
this thing on a twin mattress and I said
one day you will be on that show and you
will be a star and here you are and here
we are and it's like why not make it
official now you know handle you honey
will you accept my god are you kidding
me right now oh my god this is the worst
he's been working on this ring for a
long time I've been working with Beth's
during the great she's the only one that
other than our publicist that yes I had
to tell him because I know he'd have a
heart attack no one else knows about
this your dad last night I pulled him
out of the hotel that's what I told him
up yes to tell him right after I told my
mom
so the ring is going on it is do it to
rob attachment right Marie you should be
crying this one how do you serious mean
of course what do you think the ring
[Music]
gonna be a married woman finally love
you so much let's see the rock did I do
okay nice ring right that thought was
outrageously great you got your hot
chick I just feel like when I leave
she's gonna go okay really yeah the ring
is gonna come off no 19 years it's about
[ __ ] time with you too right I am
like so shocked I am I cannot believe
you got this past me listen this is a
happy moment it really is beautiful